what you are currently watching is a
sped up version of me playing some brain
training games which i do every morning
there are many different phone apps just
like this one which have similar games
and they're characterized into different
areas of brain cognition such as maths
learning attention speed memory and
problem solving
that's one of the reasons why i like use
on this app as i can see my score in
each of these different areas
now my scores probably look quite good
but i've had over a year of practice now
and the results don't really surprise me
my brain is quite fast i like to
problem-solve and it's flexible
and my language and memory let me down
but have i genuinely improved my mental
ability over time or have i just got
really good at playing the games on
these apps
well let's discuss
our brains represent only two percent of
our body weight get it receives 15
percent of our cardiac output
20
total body oxygen consumption and 25
total body glucose utilization
if you take care of your brain your
brain will take care of you
this is a quote i took from dave
asprey's book superhuman which i read
over two years ago now and ultimately it
goes along with what most people know
our brains are important for our daily
function our working memory our
executive function
and our unconscious activities however
unfortunately as we age our risk for
neurodegenerative diseases increase we
lose white matter in our brain and our
memory declines
so you bring in brain training
brain training refers to activities
purported to maintain or improve one's
cognitive ability
but whether it's apps like this chess
games sudokus or daily crosswords
does brain training provide benefits or
protect against neurodegeneration
well i was on the case
and while it didn't start too well it
didn't take me very long to find this
publication that had this to say
based on this examination
we find extensive evidence that brain
training interventions improve
performance on the trained tasks
less evidence that such interventions
improve performance on closely related
tasks and little evidence that training
enhances performance on distantly
related tasks or that training improves
everyday cognitive performance
and then i found another study
effectively reaching the same conclusion
this one was a consensus signed by 70 of
the world's leading cognitive
psychologists and neuroscientists in
2014
and their verdict was this
the strong consensus of this group is
that the scientific literature does not
support claims that the use of
software-based brain games alters neural
functioning in ways that improve general
cognitive performance in everyday life
or prevent cognitive slowing and brain
disease
so there we have it job done no known
benefits
but it's me so i didn't stop there and
actually there was a response to this
consensus letter
this response was published on the
website brainhq whereby they had this to
say there are now more than 70
peer-reviewed papers about the benefits
of the brain hq exercises from posit
science
more than 50 of those papers focus
specifically on the benefits of our
cognitive exercises and aging
now one common criticism with these
games is that brain training makes you
really good at the game you're doing but
it doesn't transfer to real life common
tasks the consensus is that these brain
training apps may lead to near transfer
for related tasks but there is
disagreement about the potential for far
transfer that would make people more
resilient to cognitive decline so i
decided to take a look at one of these
studies that seemed recent and most
relevant to the apps that i've been
using
improvement in executive function for
older adults through smartphone apps a
randomized clinical trial comparing
language learning and brain training
in this randomized clinical trial they
had 76 adults aged 65 to 75 assigned to
either 16 weeks of spanish learning
using the app during lingo or doing the
equivalent amount of brain training
using the app brainhq or there was a
control condition
and so for any of you who follow me on
twitter you probably know that i also
use duolingo watashiwa ringo does
anyway in this study they were using it
to examine executive function and so
this would be an example of near
transfer for the brain training apps but
far transfer for the people doing
duolingo and what they found was for
their two primary measures duolingo
provided equivalent benefits to brain hq
but brain hq showed a quicker reaction
time and these results were in line with
the previous ideas of language learning
that it's a demanding mental activity
involving working memory long-term
memory sustained attention and auditory
processing
and so it could provide a more effective
mental workout than other activities
and also these app-based language
training
are well at least i find them quite
enjoyable but they also have the
potential to lead to further life
enhancing activities such as taking
advantage of these new languages such as
for travel or for friendship but anyway
i didn't have time to read all 70 of
these papers and as i've been learning
about in the book i'm currently reading
how spies think i probably have some
confirmation bias in my search for
evidence
so to conclude this video and for a
search of alternative strategies to
brain training i turned to the book
better with age the psychology of
successful aging
in this book dr alan castell professor
in the department of psychology at ucla
dedicates an entire chapter to
addressing the question of can computer
games make us smarter
his verdict firstly agrees generally
with that of the consensus
computer-based training holds tremendous
promise as a way to challenge our minds
but currently there is not enough
evidence that computer-based brain
training can help us improve our memory
help us to remember names better or find
our keys
but what i like about this chapter is dr
castell also raises some important pros
and cons
the pros being that these apps and brain
training games help to stimulate and
reward our brain
and apparently they can be beneficial if
you believe it works and such placebo
effects can be powerful
however there are some things you should
be aware of
firstly you shouldn't use up your time
to do these games
if you're sacrificing the time spent on
exercise which have more evidence to
support brain cognition
in addition these games can lead to
additional screen time being sedentary
and socializing less with others the
offsetting costs here may be greater
than the actual benefits of doing these
brain training games
and in addition to exercise reading and
walking for emotional skills and
physical benefits respectively may be
better alternatives
so will i continue given the lack of
evidence
uh well yes mainly because i enjoy
playing it and i try to make sure it's
time i would have otherwise been spent
probably on social media so in my case i
think it's probably beneficial
and to some extent this is still an
emerging field and it would be hard at
least i would think so to even conduct a
study that could fairly assess the
impacts of activities like this on brain
cognition
moreover because these studies are
really hard to control for and are
either too short or too small
and so if you're like me and enjoy doing
these brain training games then why not
it doesn't cost me anything to do it
just don't assume that it's going to be
beneficial
so anyway i hope you've enjoyed this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening